lamentation du nouveau cabinet trudeau
choix d'une nouvelle chaire chez les
conservateurs
on peut dire qu encore une semaine
certains événements ont volé la vedette
alors que d'autres sont passés inaperçus
pour en discuter
je joins mes collègues qui eux ont tout
vu marie hélène tremblay sur la colline
parlementaire à québec danielle
thibeault ici à tahoua bonjour à vous
deux bonjour bonjour daniel jeu va
commencer avec vous c'est dans l'air du
temps à ottawa nouveau gouvernement au
peu en vérité on peut pas sous-estimer
l'ampleur des changements dans
l'appareil de l'état et ce qu'on a
découvert c'est que tout tout tout est
prévu même le décès de l'éventuel
premier ministre ou comme le dit le
décret emmanuel le scénario dans le cas
où le premier ministre est dans
l'impossibilité d'exercer ses fonctions
donc mort comme blessé gravement aux
présume
lorsqu'on a appris cette semaine c'est
que c'est rohff goudé le ministre de la
sécurité publique qui est le premier
remplaçant de justin trudeau sait
quelque chose lui arrive c'est suivi de
l'intimé carré le ministre de
l'agriculture et de stéphane dion le
ministre des affaires étrangères
dominique leblanc son ami d'enfance est
en 7e position
jean yves duclos et marc garneau se
partagent respectivement la 14 et 15ème
position
je pense que si on en arrive là le
gouvernement est grave problème
yann seconde laisse faut dire aussi
qu'ils prévoient le remplaçant du
remplaçant alors la personne qui devient
premier ministre a aussi deux
remplaçants c'est pour vous montrer à
quel point on prévoit à peu près toutes
les éventualités
bon voilà effet marie-hélène dans un
autre ordre d'idées le gouvernement un
couillard lui s'engage à revoir les
allocations octroyées aux anciens
premiers ministres et les parlementaires
eux veulent que les privilèges accordés
soient réduits le débat se poursuit donc
effectivement et ce qui a amené
justement le gouvernement à prendre cet
engagement cette semaine c'est parce
qu'il ya eu une étude controversée sur
la radio de québec qui a été dévoilé une
étude qui a coûté 16 mille dollars et
qui a été payé par le budget
discrétionnaire qui avait été octroyé à
l'ancienne première ministre pauline
marois
parce qu'il faut savoir que depuis 1995
les anciens premiers ministres justement
ont droit à une allocation de 200 mille
dollars par année et ce pour les trois
premières années qui suivent la fin de
leur mandat
alors la coalition avenir québec a
ramené justement à l'avancé
n justement cet engagement qui avait
pris pourtant philippe couillard au mois
de mai il ya une motion qui a été
déposée à l'assemblée nationale qui a
été adopté à l'unanimité
alors le gouvernement emmanuel va
déposer dans les prochaines semaines
peut-être même avant noël un projet de
loi essentiellement ce qu'on veut revoir
c'est l'étendue et la durée également
des privilèges qui sont accordées aux
anciens premiers ministres et ceux qui
se demandent justement si les anciens
premiers ministres canadiens évidemment
on pense à stephen harper est bien
est-ce qu'ils ont droit eux aussi un
même traitement
eh bien ce n'est pas automatique et
manuelle il faut savoir que les anciens
premiers ministres canadiens doivent
négocier avec leurs successeurs
s'ils veulent justement bénéficier
justement d'un certain montant d'argent
pour les années suivant la fin de leur
mandat
mais daniel on sait sur quoi il faut se
pencher la semaine prochaine je vais
vous dire je sais pas quelle sera la
nature de son allocation mais il ya une
personne qui a perdu son emploi et qui
s'est fait congédier cette semaine je
vais pas vous dire si celui là il ya eu
une location il s'appelle team wasyl qu
il est chef au 24 sussex depuis cinq ans
chef du premier ministre harper donc et
après une longue rencontre cette semaine
entre le responsable du personnel des
résidences du 24 sussex et madame
grégoire se fit grégoire les poses de
justin trudeau
il a indiqué que tout le monde tout le
personnel avait conservé son emploi sauf
lui
semble-t-il que c'est assez commun quand
le nouveau résident d'une résidence
officielle arrive ils amènent
semble-t-il son chef cuisinier avec lui
que ce soit le premier ministre chef
d'opposition le gouverneur général
monsieur wasyl cozzi qu'il n'est pas
amer même s'il a perdu son emploi et dit
qu'il a adoré ce qu'il a fait que ça lui
a permis de cuisiner pour les emprunts
mais aussi pour les grands de ce monde
comme un gala merkel barack obama bill
gates également
il dit qu'il est à la recherche d'un
appareil qu'elle a déjà reçu quelques
offres et l'allemagne est ce juste à
l'arrachage la cuisine est disponible
sur certains m'ont dit que ça va pas
trop de difficultés à s'en trouver je
devrais aller qu'il faudra nous dévoiler
qui le nouveau cuisinier de la famille
chercher l'eau dès que vous allez savoir
à vous deux vous remercie d'avoir été
des nôtres
merci merci